to explain no no i'm going to ask you
i'm asking you a question my opinion my
question
undo an answer
i'll do an answer are you going to
triple down today are you going to come
in and do the right thing
the nevada state athletic commission
chairman holding metro's feet to the
proverbial fire as they discuss an
investigative report into a deadly
fraternity boxing match
thanks for joining us here at new and
i'm heather mills the nevada state
athletic commission addressing that
match after a report was released by the
state attorney general's office
twenty-year-old unlv student nate
valencia died from his head injuries
after that charity boxing match in a
report first revealed yesterday by our
eye team the ag's office found a number
of failures in event planning it also
criticizes metro police for not
gathering enough evidence and limiting
its investigation into permit violations
not valencia's death
yesterday metro disputed those findings
now metro is answering questions about
that report we'll have the full story
coming up here at 8 news now this
evening